pour nous c'est le vrai lancement
aujourd'hui cela c'est vrai démarrage de
ces primaires pour sa rentrée politique
alain juppé et son équipe ont choisi les
yvelines entouré de jean pierre raffarin
et de gérard larcher le candidat à la
primaire de la droite et du centre a
tenu un meeting à chatou le 27 août
dernier un déplacement placé sous le
signe du dialogue avec les français et
les représentants des collectivités
locales
je m'appuie beaucoup sur les élus locaux
sur les berges avoir débuté que j'ai
beaucoup rencontrés tout au long de ces
deux années
je suis moi-même mer donc on se parle de
collègues à collègues comme je le dis
souvent ils sont un peu l'ossature de la
république qui sont toujours en première
ligne vis-à-vis de leurs concitoyens à
leur grande force c'est précisément
cette proximité que vous évoquez et
alain juppé compte de nombreux soutiens
dans le département avec dans leurs
rangs des élus yvelinois c'est une bonne
chose aussi parce qu'une grande
manifestation républicaine pour la ville
de chatou on en parle on parlait jusqu'à
présent des impressionnistes pour son
pôle culturel maintenant on va en parler
pour le jour 1 de l'accession au pouvoir
d'alain juppé j'espère en avril 2017 et
le pacte gagnant gagnant qu'il propose
avec les élus de terrain qui sont
finalement les personnes les plus
proches de nos administrés va me va bien
pour l'équipe d'alain juppé les meetings
se poursuivre
les candidatures pour la primaire
doivent être déposées avant le 9 pour le
début de la campagne officielle prévue
le 21 septembre